Okay, but let's not just stop at zero, let's keep going. What happens if we had
negative exponents? I would have 3 to the negative 1, so I know I have to take 1
and divide it by 3. I remember dividing by a number is the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal. So, 1 divided by 3 is the same thing as 1 times 1
3rd. 1 3rd is the reciprocal of 3 and I get 1 3rd. If I had 3 to the negative 2,
I'd need to divide this again by 3. I know dividing by 3 is the same thing as
multiplying by a reciprocal. So I have 1 3rd and then times 1 3rd and I get 1
9th. The same is true for 3 to the negative 3. I would take 1 9th and divide it
by 3. When I divide 19th by 3, it's the same thing as multiplying by the
reciprocal. So I have 1 9th times 1 3rd, the reciprocal of 3. So I get 1 27th.